[Music]
what up what up what up what up what up
how you livin how you doing how you
feeling it is the lef koe min and I'm
here with embers hammer buddy I like
that I'm the hammer now I uh I'm
exhausted
yeah crazy week holy crap did you enjoy
Vegas did you have fun I did I had the
one regret I have is I wasn't with you
at the craps table when it seemed like
everyone and their mother was earning a
grand at least
oh man when you win in Vegas it's a
beautiful city and when you win in craps
it's a beautiful time but Vegas and
craps can both turn very quickly well
that's why I really like the flight to
Vegas on like a Friday afternoon and
everyone's hopeful everyone's gonna win
money yeah and then the flight back on
like Sunday night we I took the red-eye
you know and like people have mixed
emotions on that flight it's uh no we
had a good time Ingmar is a big-time
poker player and I enjoy sitting next to
him at the poker table
as you steal people's souls you held
your own at that table I did okay you
made some money it's good when you're
there I get more loose and then I say
screw it and then I'll just throw bets
out there on the river and people
followed know my go this is great sure
but no it's fun watching you take
people's souls and I doubled up I
doubled up on the weekend
nice yeah and then I was able to kind of
bankroll all of my future bets which was
nice so a few things this would I have
right here is a super contest card I am
officially in the super contest if you
follow the left go show on Instagram and
it says left goes LOX is my team name
which means that this year as part of
the content where we're gonna do our
betting show on Thursdays with a special
guest host who I can't announce yet I
will be making my super contest picks
which is you pick five games against the
spread and if you are the most accurate
at the end of the year so 5 times 16 is
what mr. math whiz oh my god your times
17 5 times 17 that's gonna be 55 35 is
85 yeah
if we're the most accurate we will make
1.4 million dollars after tax about 600
K so fairness a wrongly
who's 800,000 oh I'm sorry I meant 800 K
you'd lose 600 thousand let's talk about
that really to all the homies the young
homies are like just getting paid checks
for the first time and then you see your
taxes come out there is no more
harrowing experience
there was a seeing time there was a
viral video of someone who's like
younger brother just got his first paper
route you know and he got his first
paycheck and it was he was expecting to
make I don't know $300 actually like 190
and he's just like breaks down crying
that really is that is the moment where
you're sitting at home and you're doing
the math and you're like I'm gonna make
this much money I'll be able to afford
this and then the paycheck comes in
you're like what F but then once you get
a little bit older you're like but it is
nice having roads and it's nice having
police forces and stuff but I want to
give a special shout out to Bill Kraken
burger crack wins and his guy Esposito
and all the people at the crack winds
account they're bankrolling me yeah they
want it they want to hang out we're
gonna compete with crack during the year
and guess what he's not even the special
guest gambling host so that will be
announced sometime next week I think and
I think we'll hear from Krakens we're
gonna hear from crack we're gonna be
competing he's my proxy for people that
don't know what that is I'm gonna tell
them what pics I want and you have to
enter in Vegas so he will be going to
the window one of the greatest gamblers
in the world right now is making my
picks for me and I did find that really
strange that you can't email your pics
so there's not some internal server
where you can upload your pics or
somebody that you physically have to
have a human being go into the West Gate
and I think it's because like a legal
gambling like like otherwise people
could just be gambling all over the
place where it's not legal I don't know
yeah they must have their reasons for I
was just surprised when I learned that
fact so the fact that you now have a
proxy who is in Vegas 24/7 you know it's
nice it's and it's funny I was like
walking up to the window with crack and
like people being like hey what's up man
and be like oh man you really are the
guy here that's crazy and then Kelly in
Vegas works at bleacher report and was
also in that action Showtime
she sent me a picture of somebody's in a
different contest their team name was
not left goes long yeah and I don't know
who it is I love that though so I'm
wondering are they trying to get the
good juju because as that all of our
listeners know people love to come from
my neck because of the name left coast
locks and if somebody wins a super
contest with a name not left goes locks
incredible it's gonna [ __ ] kill me no
I think that's great okay so wait so you
have 85 pics that you're gonna make I
mean no one can expect to win this thing
they're just gonna be a lot of coin
flips out there a lot of beads average
most people set around 50% okay
professional gamblers are shooting for
55 percent right if you hit 60 percent
you're incredible and crack has told me
that the winning percentage for the last
few years has been 70 percent so some
people just go on these wild season long
rides of hitting 70 percent winners
against the sprint so you'd basically
have to be like 60 and 15 or 59 and 16
on the year which is we're trying to
average around like 3.5 for a week out
of 5 which is insane that's crazy I'm so
how are you gonna pick your 5 games
you're just gonna feel it out like well
predict any of the fine be planning to
use a little bit of the expertise from
the special guest host gambling guy I'm
gonna pick his brain I have a feeling
I'm gonna be competing against crack so
I'm not gonna pick his brain but I'm
just gonna I'm gonna do what I always do
and you haven't experienced this yet
which is just 24 hours of poring over
numbers and going back and forth and
back and forth and saying I don't
[ __ ] know yeah yeah it's really when
you realize it's a 50/50 draw but you're
sitting there freaking out over a third
string quarterback and it's not even
gonna impact the game
nothing challenges your ability to know
football more mm-hmm and gambling off a
ball can I give you a suggestion of how
I pick games sure and I'm good at
picking games I'm okay I mean I'm not
I'm not great at it I be in Vegas
confidence I'm just telling you if you
have okay I'm just telling you if you
have like a coin flip or something what
I like to do is I like to sit down and
guess what the line would be if I say to
myself what I do too
if I say like okay Ravens three and a
half and
I look online it's actually Ravens
one-and-a-half I'm like okay now I found
it efficiency so you have to set the
lines because I found that if you look
at the lines first they influence you I
think that a team is what I do is I go
through and I go through all the games
straight up and I circle who I think is
gonna win the game then look at the
lines then I look at the lines and if
there's any games in which that team is
the underdog right I'm like that's what
I'm gonna bet on smart that's yeah cuz
if you look at the lines first you're
[ __ ] right because they influenced the
hell out of you yes you're like oh if
Caesars believes that this team six and
a half points better when you talk to
like the Warren sharps and the Bill
crack and burgers of the world you
realize that's not the line of what they
think is gonna happen it's the line to
influence betting you're like oh this is
this is crazy right I would like to
announce though I did use crack and I
did use sharp I did use Bill Kraken
burger and I did use sharp to help me
make my season-long bets yes if you want
to jump on these with me be more than
willing to it I'm gonna bring in the
tickets I'm gonna put them up on the
wall of that because I think we need to
remind myself and with their help these
are the five bets that I've come up with
that I've already put $1,000 of my own
money
god bless that craps table yeah I
thought it was like and I'm using this
for other gambling so it's not a
thousand dollars of your own money it's
a thousand dollars of Caesars money yeah
thanks a lot Suze I appreciate it thanks
to Ben for that hot roll for those of
you like I'm not I'm not here saying
that you guys should go gamble I learned
how to play craps from Travis Kelce hmm
from our Tahoe trip and the other rule
of craps is as soon as you lose or as
soon as you win leave get out of there
which is a wild thing to say and it's
hard in the moment when you feel the
juice going same with blackjack right
you're yours your stacks gone from 500
to 900 and it's like just believe dude I
never asked you what did you think of
the way I play blackjack
well I the thing that I was fascinated
by was we were looking for a $25 minimum
table and I was like okay $25 is still a
lot of action on one you know one hand
but then you were up to fifty
seventy-five hundred dollars a hand like
within five minutes like dude what are
you searching for it because really when
it comes down to by the way you know I
lost that last one I went back with 200
I turn it into seven so I was able to
leave I felt pretty good out of there
but it's really I can't
this much about gambling we just got
back from Vegas back to [ __ ] off it
really comes down to the dealer they're
like there will be dealers that I will
sit down and go I hate this person and
I'm not the kind of person that talks
crap to the dealers I think those people
are sick that they're like thanks a lot
for that I'm like [ __ ] you like but when
they that's when I need a lower minimum
to wait them out mm-hmm I'm waiting for
a shift change yeah where I'm waiting
for a new shoe because I want the
minutes to be low when I'm like I'm not
nope nope nope no and that's such a sick
feeling okay anyway five bets the one
that I put them there were two that I
put the most money down on but one of
them is the Eagles winning the NFC East
it's becoming a more popular bet now but
I think I got it like minus 150 I think
I put $280 on it Eagles winning the NFC
East it's the rare time where something
I believe something I'm rooting for and
something that the Sharps are all over a
line and for me I want to I already have
$20 on the Eagles to win the Super Bowl
of twenty to one okay so like let's keep
going yeah it's gonna be really shitty
when they hit the bed this year second
one is one that I did that I'm not sure
about but the Sharps were all over was
Seahawks missing the playoffs I think
that I it makes a lot of sense from my
football brain which is the Rams are
gonna be competitive
I expect the Niners to be a lot better I
think there's three teams in the NFC
North that are fighting for a spot there
are two or three teams in the south
whether it's Saints Panthers and the
Falcons play 13 straight games in a dome
to start the season and then Eagles
Cowboys so really what you're betting
there is the Rams could be better than
the Seahawks and then there's six teams
fighting for that other wildcards per
share so I understand it I also don't
like betting against Russell Wilson and
Pete Carroll at the same point their
defense with Earl Thomas leaving and I
know that they performed well of him
being gone last year they also lose
Frank Clark I'm still not sure about
that offensive line
and no one's really talking about this a
lot
Doug Baldwin's gone mm-hmm and I don't
think people realize how big of a deal
that was especially when they're there
big time wide receiver who has a K in
their name gosh
screw the the big one OD k Metcalfe
thank you yeah [ __ ] the fantasy
footballers that keep confusing PK
Metcalf and Nikhil Harry
sir I just did it to me so screw you
hitman but III look at that and go Doug
Baldwin was so reliable for them yeah
and made so many big catches and now
it's the Tyler Lockett show can also say
Doug Baldwin is my number one I want to
be friends with him NFL player of all
time really I did a thing with him I was
in a room with him for like a half hour
and I was kind of directing a thing that
he was shooting and by the end I was
like I just want to be friends with you
smart guy smart dude seemed like
genuinely funny engaged and I was like I
just yeah he's one of my top picks for
want to be friends with so that's one
where I go I could totally see the
Seahawks making the playoffs but all the
Sharps were like loved this one wasn't
okay all right next one is a team that I
was doubting and the Sharps love and
when you think about it makes a little
bit of sense Carolina over eight at
first I was like I'm afraid of Cam
Newton shoulder I was like sure they
started off really strong last year and
then they faded and like I don't know if
I trust Greg Olson
Sharp's were all over it and so because
of that I aligned with that really I
just suckered out and bet all the ones
of the Sharks were like kind of sold me
well they spend the time doing it you
spend your time doing other kinds of
prep for your podcast and for your show
and for whatever other stuff no chase
that the Tampa Bay Bucs are in the south
like that's why it's really hard for me
to bat during the season cuz I go well
what is let the people who spend their
hours is their day doing this stuff let
the cracks so then my job is to pass it
along because as I've always said if I
get access to somebody I want the 33
percent if I have access to some of the
best gamblers in the world right and I
can get their information for free I'm
gonna pass along to the 33% so Eagles
when the NFC East Sea Hawks missed the
playoffs Carolina over eight Baltimore
over eight I feel really good about okay
the Baltimore Ravens
our zigging when everyone else is
sagging right now and if I'm gonna be
super confident about Pete Carroll I
believe that you should have that same
towards John Harbaugh because Harbaugh
has shown that every year he's
competitive and when you look at the
fact that if with the sealing of what
Earl Thomas
and and those guys can bring to that
defense if they're healthy they they're
gonna stay at the same level we know
about wink Martindale Don Martindale the
defensive coordinator and and how big
they are up at upfront and if they're
willing to move on from CJ Mosley
they've built CJ Mosley's in the past
and I I think that I trust that team a
lot defensively offensively
I am very high on this team compared to
what all of the PFF people are saying
and I'm not just talking about Lamar
Jackson this is a team that went what
six and one with Lamar Jackson down the
stretch last year I believe that Lamar
Jackson's gonna be a lot better and
we're gonna have a whoa big offseason
coming up about them again but I also
look at this stable of running backs
whether it's Mark Ingram Gus Edwards the
running the rookie running back justice
Hill I look at their wide receivers and
I see Miles Boykin the the rookie but
also the kid Hollywood Brown then you
factor in Willie Snead who I love a lot
but also like four or five tight ends
Marc Edwards Nick Boyle Hayden Hurst who
they took in the first round and an
offensive line they have the tools to
bash people's faces in the entire NFL is
going to pass pass pass and the Ravens
are going
it's like facing Georgia Tech in college
football all year you're playing passing
and then here comes the triple option
and it's like no you need to tackle 470
plays so an you of Justin Tucker and and
just the offense got so much better when
Joe Flacco left there just a very end
and my my better mind says to bet
against the Cleveland Browns and I also
think that the Steelers have to take a
step back right so I love Ravens over
eight and the other one is Washington
under six I can't believe that washing
is even that high I think the lowest in
the NFL right now then the Dolphins are
at like four and a half but that
Washington was at six and a half it's
come down to six but I look at this team
I think Case Keenum is gonna be starting
I don't expect Trent Brown Anat Trent
Brown Trent Williams to play at all this
year
I also go I know I love Washington's
defense and and and Greg Mineski and
what he can do but I just have to think
that when you're team captain doesn't
trust the [ __ ] team the ripple
effects must be crazy
mm-hmm must be crazy so I love
Washington under six I have a prediction
for this bet because here we're gonna be
following it throughout the whole season
at five for like the last three weeks so
he's gonna say it's gonna be they're
gonna be like two and seven or two and
eight and you're gonna say one thing
where you're like oh that bets locked up
you're gonna sit ya know you're gonna
slip in your me that well I will never
talk that like I saw something on the B
are betting page or they're like all we
got to do is hit this last one and I was
like bet you they don't hit that last
one right never talk about it and I'm
gonna say this to you now if you ever
say something about my bets to kick me I
will hold you wholly responsible for
them it just strikes me as this sort of
thing because every year there's that
team that's like two and six two and
seven twenty you forget about them then
they win like four of their last five or
whatever I feel like that could be I had
Miami
I had Miami over seven and I had Buffalo
under six mmm sweaty had seven Buffalo
had five going to the final week of the
year right playing each other ah and I
pushed both because Buffalo beat Miami
so I lost both not lost but those are
the bats Eagles when the NFC East
Washington under six Baltimore over
eight Carolina over eight Seahawks
missed the playoffs and really I really
should be listening to because you've
already won one bet Eddie [ __ ] Panero
is seemingly right now the kicker for
the Chicago Bears Elliott Frey was cut
and I'm not convinced Banaras gonna be
their kicker though because have you
seen the Carli Lloyd clips from this
morning no what was the Harley Lloyd
World Cup champion she had a hat trick
in the the World Cup final previous 2015
she came in and she just knocked a
yarder through that knocked a 55 yarder
through like wheels practice like it was
nothing and I'm saying like if you're if
you're the Chicago Bears and Eddie
paneros starting to look like a head
case at some point I'm rooting for you
Eddie Panero I'm just saying like Carli
Lloyd is in your rear view mirror right
now I also think that it might not be
Eddie Pinero because this is the first
year in a long time where there's like
three or four kickers on other teams
Carolina had one has one Baltimore
already traded theirs to Minnesota where
they're like they're trot him out there
in preseason to try and get like a six
or a seventh round pick back right and
and Chicago already played the Panthers
and the dude on the Panthers the backup
to Graham Cano went three for three and
like one of them was like 56 yards or
something like that they could still go
through all this and then try and steal
somebody yeah they might just be doing a
little lake in the gladiator night you
won this round and and you're blaming
Elliott Fry's social media account I'm
not blaming it I'm just saying that when
choosing a random guy of this guy over
that guy you know Eddie Panero I'm glad
I went with him because his entire
Instagram is just football
100% football all the time football and
look everyone's allowed to have a fun
social life I'm sure that he's not 100
percent football all the time I'm sure
he likes to play video games or watch TV
or whatever he does but the fact that I
looked on his Instagram and the only
things you can find going back to May of
2016
oh yeah yeah there was there was bikini
pictures there was Christmas parties and
look I don't begrudge the guy you have a
life I'm just saying for the fun of just
about these guys yeah so congrats thank
you
Eddie Panero here my guy shoutout to all
the homies that hit me up on social
media Elliott fry and feel bad for him
LF GL left go fantasy gridiron lead the
let's [ __ ] go let's go summer coming
up I think most people are drafting
Thursday night we will be headed to DC
but we're gonna find a way to get to a
hotel quickly yes and and do our dress
you're drafting has that have you gone
on to the sleeper up yet and looked
around yes I have and also I've been in
a nice little chat thread shout out to
the let's [ __ ] go League my like 12
that I'm doing this the league wit they
were like say me your league do you know
got it it's something funny I've totally
forgot I should have looked shout out to
all the great I know one of them
was like sharp like warren sharp has an
amazing mustache oh it's called a let he
who is without Sims cast the first stone
say what was it let he who is without
Sims cast the first that's phenomena and
what pic do you have IV 11th pick which
I like I like that too so cuz I think
it's like McCaffrey and chimera and all
that stuff that's gonna sort itself out
whoever falls to me I'll grab him and
I'll be happy with it and I won't be
bummed when like the guy that I picked
number three overall gets injured I just
let whoever comes to me at eleven
whether it's you know yes whoever I
don't know who it's gonna be about so
William use L for helping set up if
you're listening right now and you're
like holy crap I still haven't heard
back
DM William ezel on instagram @ w GE the
number two so W GE to and he might be
able to help you out but I think we're
we're kind of closing in now you guys
are incredible for doing this my league
and I'm in Ezell's League my league is
called the capital hmm and he asked me
what I wanted to be called I said I want
to be called the capital because my
league is in my mind in like Hunger
Games I was gonna say it's Hunger Games
a capital and the other ninety something
leagues are all the districts and
everybody wants to kick my ass yeah so
we'll see what happens into the year I'm
hoping I can be I think Ezell's in my
league - he got that honor but you know
we're the cap so you're the capital and
then like you're just you're like
district the other the other 96
districts are just fighting each other
for your amusement until they're ready -
for the big the big matchup I honestly
think it might be something we do next
year where that league is like whoever
are like the champion gets to be in that
league - yeah maybe you'll be it I kind
of like you in another league though I'm
just I'm just out here myself but so I
got the first pick and I told ezel I was
like bro you didn't have to do that
because I randomised it and you got
first one in 12 shot yeah
should I announce who I'm taking yeah
well I I told everybody that was going
with Travis Kelce and they're like ooh
wildcard I was like I'm not going Travis
Kelce you should take any Panera a lot
of field goals this year [ __ ] funny
but also what is your what is your
relationship with fantasy football right
now I'm glad you asked
I've been playing it probably every year
except for one year
where I just didn't email the guy back
in time my buddy I'd been this league
for seven years and you get the email in
July and I'm like yeah I'll get to it
and then I just completely forgot they
got another guy in the league so I
played every year except for one since
I'm like 15 years old and every year I
don't enjoy it but I do it every year
it's I get so excited here then like
week six I'm like why am i spending so
much [ __ ] time on Tuesday night's
preparing for the waiver wire yeah this
is not productive what I was so it's
that thing of you make the right
decision based on whatever Yahoo told
you or whatever sleeper app tells you
this guy's gonna core 17 points but this
guy's gonna swear 14 points so you put
the 17 point guy and your starting
lineup and you sit the 14 point guy of
course the guy that you played shits the
bed and has one catch for nine yards the
guy you put on the bench like threw a
touchdown pass randomly and like you
know had nine receptions it's it's that
thing that just drives you crazy but
what I was gonna say is around week
seven or eight is when I check in with
how much I hate it and I email my
friends and what I like is when my team
is pretty good and I'm like six and two
or five and three and I'm in the mix I
then have a lot more impact when I say
that I hate fantasy cuz no one thinks
I'm a poor sport oh if your team sucks
and you go fantasy football sucks that
like what you're just saying that
because just cuz you draft you drafted a
shooting team Burnett and he got hurt
it's like no even when my team's doing
well I still I get stressed about it I
feel bad about myself my wife I mean
could not give less of a [ __ ] I'm
sitting there watching football on a
Sunday and I'm like how are you not
throwing the ball to Dez Bryant what's
going on and and and she's like is this
you're a Patriots fan like why are you
getting so upset about
random cowboys Bengals game I would
estimate that I've done in the last
month upwards of 600 mock drafts sick
it's not an exaggeration this sleeper
app you can crank out like 40 mocks an
hour you're like one of those online
poker Yahoo and I'm like doing a mock on
Yahoo and like by the second round it's
all become automation so it's like
people just it's like accounts drafting
whoever's first by the way one note I
have a feeling that the sleeper drafts
are alphabetical so like right please
don't come unprepared to your draft and
then like expect to take who then
number one person is there and you're
looking at like a mere Abdullah and
you're like what the [ __ ] that would be
funny though with 1200 people or
whatever it is in your linear duel will
end up being like the most drafted guy
and like if you look down someone's
fantasy draft' and like it's all A's and
B's then you know that they just were
just clicking clicking typing it's
really it'll be the same way that magic
Johnson makes his lists mm-hmm you know
what I mean in your draft this is
something that I think will impact
everybody if Zeke is available when
you're drafting do you take him it
depends on value right I know that's at
11:00 at 11:00 no I'm not taking Zeke at
11:00 isn't that wild no because he
might be like he might miss six weeks
and I would rather have a a less good
running back for 16 about what about the
second round second pick of the second
round if he's still there
I might text you in a panic and be like
what should I do
I think I just think it's really
interesting and I think to take real
football and to talk about fantasy
football
Le'Veon Bell was the first time where we
saw this happen and I've had a lot of
got like so my two instances I had one
dude in my league torch that drafted
levy on bail and I was like I am NOT
drafting him at all and he did and I had
James Conner and so he went through a
whole year and he feels bad about it of
course I hosted an auction draft and the
number one player that was bought that
was argued over the most was Le'Veon
Bell and in auction dress you get about
$200 somebody spent 90 of their $200
almost 50% of their money on levy on
bail right and they didn't make the
playoffs and so I think this is the
first year because we saw someone
actually do it where before it would go
Zeke misses one or two weeks what do you
do now and now it's like [ __ ] man this
might keep going on and then when you
factor it in what's happened where Jerry
Jones is going Zeke ooh and they're
pumping up Tony Pollard it becomes like
I might still get great value for Zeke
in the beginning of the second round but
like do I want a sure thing and I don't
even want to deal with that [ __ ] yeah
and sometimes you just make a decision
right there in the moment it's like the
poker table sometimes you know you're
making the the right call or you're
making the wrong call but you're like I
have to see that what this guy has I
have to see if this guy's bluffing me
you just you're sitting there and all in
the back your mind is screaming this is
a danger pick like Zeke might you know
might not be getting you good value here
in the second round but you just you see
his name out there and you're like I
just want him on my team but I got one
of my Gordon Melvin Gordon I would not
be surprised if he doesn't play at all
this year how I feel and it feels like
that could be a bitterness situation
where they limit his carries just to
like prove a point I don't know
so what round would you even think about
drafting Melvin Gordon I've done so many
machs yeah you're you're I'm seeing like
so I'm seeing some mocks I see Zico in
the top four mm-hmm some mocks I see
Zico in the bottom four of the first
round you can't base it he'd never seen
him leave the first round really no but
I mean mocks it's like it's it costed
the preseason NFL you can't base
anything based on the score of them no
but just like you're talking about poker
you're not always playing what the hands
are you're playing the person yeah and
so mocks give you a good example of a DP
average trap position yeah and where
they're going I have not seen Zeke leave
the first round Melvin Gordon I'm seeing
going anywhere from the 2nd to the 4th
so that's the rain I had fourth round in
my head I still don't know if I would
take Melvin Gordon in the fourth I can
get a pretty good running back that I
know is gonna play in the fourth round
Ameer Abdullah amazing right there the
top of the list and I fouled out with
Aaron Rodgers followed by an aardvark
and JJ are saiga Whiteside all right
they go Whiteside but I think it's and
then what about a Antonio Brown would
you draft Antonio Brown with hell yeah
would you I believe last night's episode
kind of got me believing again we
talking Hard Knocks now yeah ok I raised
it from the dead ok I thought last
night's episode or this week's episode
was the best hard knocks of the season
yeah I got totally sucked in on Waller
I'm like I'm a believer in the
redemption singers talk about a fantasy
guy like he was like an under-the-radar
fantasy guy Titan I think he gets like
the Hard Knocks bump I'm saying cuz
everyone's talking like Kelsey Hertz and
your guy kettle right like that's that's
your undisputed top 3 and nothing else
alerts then there's that second wave of
like OJ Howard Hunter Henry and have an
Ingram and like we as fantasy players
are waiting for someone to like
rise from the ashes of that second third
tier and be it's like the sixth tier
that's what I'm saying if Waller just
comes in and is like he become like he
and Derek are buddies I think there's
Antonio Browns like hobbling around so
they got to go somewhere else - yeah
like too small in the red zone like you
just get what yeah he might be manfro I
honestly feel so bad for him now dude
he's having the best season I dude
everyone [ __ ] on him all the time in
these episodes his life that's what he
was like it he's a five foot ten white
guy like in fact that the fact that
Gruden's like we want to get bigger
stronger faster so he rescued and hunter
renfro's like oh guys like why are you
making foot and they showed his clips
from Clemson and I got hyped yeah but
like he they weren't showing it to him
so that was something as a fan that you
were like holy [ __ ] look at spin move
look at that stiff arm by Hunter
renfro's he's athletic is he only clips
with Hunter Renfro in it
we're derrick karr being like what's
wrong with your receding hairline I
don't ever be like everywhere every
Renfro from generations has had this
hairline do you think now that you're 37
years old and then grew and then but the
thing is I love is Gruden loves them
Curtin's like look at Renfro yeah and uh
renfro's doing it for the unathletic
what like hunter renfro's really doing
it for all the guys in their beer league
softball I think they can make you just
accidentally said he's unathletic I
think he's actually very athletic but
we're being oh yeah like we're we're
thinking that he's kind of is like
aesthetically right he does not look at
that if he walked into a bar he wouldn't
be like that guy plays in the NFL no I'd
be like if I had to fight one guy in
this bar I'm most confident against
already also his name is hunter Renfro
yeah you know but I felt bad for him
they were talking about his singing the
entire time but the happy birthday John
grew do not know how to sing happy
birthday so I I've had this discussion
because you know I've worked in music
and stuff and in my past and I worked
with this amazing music director his
name is Bryan Yusuf Aries the music
director of like some Broadway shows and
stuff that you've heard of any big ones
oh yeah Book of Mormon no Chozen yeah
yeah he's holy [ __ ] he's worked on some
major major stuff anyway he and I were
talking and he's an incredible musician
but not a great singer and he would sing
something like this would be like happy
birthday to you like that's about how he
would sing that's the new birth
but the notes are correct yes you don't
have to be a good singer in order to
have the notes correct it's just like
when I ask for your phone number
you don't go 8 6 7 4 3 2 1 no there's a
pattern it's papa papa
happy birthday is Papa Papa it's not a
[ __ ] broad that's what I'm saying you
don't have to be a good singer in order
to sing the recognizable melody of the
song happy birthday to you I'm like what
is in your ears that's the way you
thought the song gotta leave that he
didn't give the pause people go let's
sing happy birthday for David one two
three he went let's sing happy birthday
for David happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you and I'm like what the
floor and it was driving me crazy as
someone that loves music it's like dude
just sing the song normal just I also
love to that there's that really awkward
moment Ted Ted Ted
and then like you're like what name are
we saying Mike Mike or it's also like GM
like people that say full names and the
happy birthday song are so [ __ ] up
we're lucky your name is Adam my name is
David right like the true sing yeah
happy birthday dear David it's easy it's
done yeah happy birthday dear Anastasio
yeah I was I was like I don't think Jon
Gruden knows any of this and it made me
think like is Jon Gruden such a football
guy that no one ever celebrated it out
with that it's not it that's not it I
promise you that's not it it's that
thing where people get in their head
there's two skills in life where people
say I suck at it and then they give up
on it it seemed just begin drawing woo
people say I suck at drawing and then
they intentionally tanked any doodle
that they do for the rest of their life
but yeah and then when they when someone
says like I suck at singing that's fine
to suck at singing but you can still
sing lips with a gesture toward the song
that you're attempting to perform
I've also by the way completely changed
how I do birthday songs I mean I only do
the Stevie Wonder song happy birthday -
was that what he was trying to do
because that's kind of the descending
million way that Jon Gruden was doing
now like I don't want I don't want to
offend anybody whatever but my fiance
tells me that's the black happy birthday
song happy
and what's really funny is we went to a
birthday party where I was like the only
white guy there and we're in the middle
of a restaurant and they're like garlic
saying happy birthday and I pretty sure
the waitress went with happy and the
whole thing went happy birthday - yeah
and what's really funny is is there's a
part after you get done where it goes
hey B burn and that's when the entire
[ __ ] restaurant like turned it was
like what is going on right now
because it was so musical and it was so
in sync and I was enjoying every second
of it that I've just decided that's the
birthday song that one that's great
that's what I want yeah I I don't mind
the classic because I love the when
people are clapping people getting into
it yeah it's a good song better yeah
okay
other hard-knock stuff we we finally got
behind the scenes reactions into the
Antonio Brown story yeah as what you're
waiting for a true Rosenhaus true
rosanell is going up to Gruden i think
we got this figured out i think we're
gonna make this work you know Gruden and
Mayock reacting we got him we finally
got him here but we're seeing Antonio
Brown interact with people getting that
double drip you know that that really
juicy Gatorade talking about his feet oh
man I cut it off I want to say this too
we can we can make fun of Antonio Brown
and we can get annoyed at this storyline
and talk about how it's frustrating but
I also want to say this he's a [ __ ]
baller mm-hmm the fact that he is still
getting things cut off of his feet and
he's still gone I need to go and run
today mm-hmm
men lie women lie analytics don't lie oh
that was interesting that little like
statcast thing that's tough as much as
we want to say that Antonio Brown has
ego as much as we want to say that he's
being a distraction one thing I will
never say is that dude isn't working his
ass off if my if the bottom of my feet
were falling off of the bone ain't no
way I'm running to see how it feels
today but he's that much of an intensity
he has in his brain there are certain
athletes that have this ability to go
adversity makes me stronger yeah that's
all I've done I'm not built like that I
don't think you're built like that like
we're good against adversity oh no
there's a point I had a slip disc in my
back and like I haven't played sports in
like 11 months as a result like I'm not
pushing anything there's no upside to me
doing like some Roma elbow you know I
mean like it's I just want to I don't
want it to come off as though that every
time we talk about him being an
annoyance that we don't appreciate what
he's going through right now to me was
it done that it happened sure he's an
impressive what he's doing to get back
very much so in my mind I thought the
John Abram conversation on the bench
where they were talking about getting
cottonmouth on the field and needing to
chew gum and then like Jonathan Abram
and vantes perfect being like I probably
swallowed 200 pieces of gum in my life
and like the future parent and me was
like stop swallowing gum it's the one
rule you learn when you're six years old
and then dick in your system for nine
years
here Whitehead was like yo that's why
you guys are constipated all the time
your stomach is full of gum like I like
Johnny I'm like I'm really worried right
now for you bro what about John Abram
next to our guy Clint Oldenburg that's
yes Madden Madden ratings adjuster
Clinton Oldham very man you guys will
see coming up on ditch the playbook but
know that it was funny to see like my
NFL son and then like Clinton older
manly friend I Madden friend anything
else from the show that kind of stuck
out to you salad of the year what Luke
Wilson's hair he's got that beautiful
salad just flowing in the breeze on that
but I have I have drank with Trancas
that's right I have drunk yeah I drank
with him where I have drunk I drank with
Luke Wilson and I've like kind of kicked
it with him when he said he should be a
hockey player 100% when you he's like
broke just letting you know like he has
that hockey vibe to him you're familiar
with the Minnesota hockey videos that
come out every year right okay so do
they come out I don't know they're like
these beautiful unicorns that just pop
out of nowhere guys Google Minnesota
hair hockey that should get you to it
it's like this random dude that so
there's a big hockey tournament in
Minnesota every year the states and
these kids grow out these luxurious
Mane's and they that's made and so you
have these videos where they like skate
out and then like flip their hair now
in on it all these dollar idea so and
everyone's trying to reach the top ten
and the dude that does the video has
this beautiful Minnesota Oh fun he's
like take a look at the lettuce here on
old Johnny sweet oh man really good flow
so as I was working with as I was
watching that video and I see like Luke
Wilson just hanging on a boat with his
dad with like that's those sunglasses
and just like just look it up at the
Golden Gate Bridge I was like that dude
needs to be in a salad video last thing
all in this episode with was I think
part of what added to John Gruden's
legacy was the fact that he was miked up
for the Super Bowl when Tampa Bay beat
Oakland yeah one of my theories that
because he gave access to a game in
which they beat the other team by 30
their clips that whenever people are
showing Super Bowl stuff we always see
Jon Gruden going like you always see
that and then in heppa soda for the
preseason game he goes boof and I go did
you just yell boof like I have a theory
about that that a bee came into town and
boom in is his thing like this cool
little like I guess it was a hand warmer
or whatever that no that's it's like a
back pass a support or something yeah it
looked like one of those like back muffs
that like Jim Kelly used to wear back
okay you know but I was like it looks
like it's 90 degrees out there
but yeah so so if a bees coming in is
like boom ins my thing and Gruden's like
why can't just like so I'm boof Anan
booth I have a feeling that I might be
saying a word that's like an urban
dictionary thing so let me just double
check this really quick I know buff is a
word that's used for like marry Boff
kill instead of the way booth a jump
over hydraulic backwash in a high
gradient mountain river in action
analogous to a skier jumping a cliff and
in terms of urban dictionary yeah we're
gonna say that it's the skiing ones the
skiing what's the skiing like I'm gonna
look it up on urban dictionary the
skiing one it's just a slip of the
tongue from Burton and there's nothing
to do with any of this you have a theory
about Antonio Brown just to wrap up Hard
Knocks which a good job HBO
yeah my thing and and you've had this
experience as much as anyone when you
get someone in the booth with you right
it's a very different experience to
criticize them not to their face as
their face and a lot of people are tough
guys on Twitter a lot of people are just
like sports fans in a bar and they're
saying like man I would say to Antonio
Brown this that the other about the
helmet you're being a baby you're being
a diva you're being or whatever how
about our poker dealer he was like you
got a problem with it go drive a bus and
I was like your advice to an NFL players
to go drive a bus I know it's crazy but
it's easy to say that stuff but then you
see Jon Gruden in that final five
minutes of the episode and Antonio
Browns like thanks for having my back
out there and that was amazed and what's
Gruden's supposed to do be like hey man
you're a jerk like no he's like he's
like hey man you're on this team we love
you you're back and it into me it's it's
kind of indicative of everyone has that
friend that's in a not great
relationship their boyfriend their
girlfriend their husband their wife
whatever and they're complaining to them
you know to you about them and then they
say all these things are like man I
don't like that she does this I don't
like that he does this blah blah blah
and they're saying all that stuff and
then when they're actually back together
they're like I love you honey they never
actually like say those things out loud
right and it's kind of this I think it's
gonna be this season long saga where we
love Antonio Brown he's so charismatic
they never actually say the thing they
need to say to his face and it's gonna
be this kind of tricky thing that mike
Mayock and and Gruden and some of the
other receivers that they're gonna have
to navigate because they're gonna be
like you know saying some stuff behind
his back and i wish he wouldn't do XY
and z but then when he's in the room
they're like a B there's my guy like
that when he was tapping everybody up
when he first arrived at Camp they
couldn't look like Santa Claus I just
arrived they were so excited to see him
Richie incognito is delighted to see
like every witness that rich think I
need maybe had the exact same
conversation hey your big dude yeah the
I've always said to you know the phrase
ignorance is bliss
of course it's beyond true where you
look at people and when you're
self-aware human you look at people that
are not self-aware and there's party
that goes I wish I couldn't even process
my own emotions that I could live life
and bliss like you there is a thing with
some football players and football
coaches where I have that where Jon
Gruden a we can look at each other and
go I mean once we cut out this noise
everything is gonna be great
that they can put everything on anybody
other than the 53 people in that locker
room
they can blame every issue that they
have on their lives on reporters and
media and fans and blogs and and then
but they can look at each other and go
but I know you got my back and there's
something so ignorant about that where
you're like no like you're creating this
mess like the comments you made last
week are what's causing this issue right
now and now that I'm saying out loud it
makes me understand why life is so hard
for them when they get out of their
careers because there's no longer this
like random assortment of humans that
you can blame your issues on but in the
meantime I look at them and that's all
they kept saying man once we get past
this noise oh it's all the outside world
saw the outside world it's like no bro
it's [ __ ] you but it's any of that he
just he just was like we're great to
have you we love you in tono he did he
go he goes oh you didn't say a little
bit of a football first because thank
you for getting my back he goes man you
know how it is he goes listen I know
it's tough cuz you're like a corporation
but like once we get in here and then a
Antonio Browns like oh yeah we gonna
yeah everything get shut down man it
life is easy at that point and there's
there's something beautiful about that
and there's also something where I'm
like it's not true alright the only
other thing I was gonna say I'm just
gonna touch on the Dallas situation
really quick I do think it's kind of
crazy that Dallas is giving the money to
Jaylon Smith as their very publicly
dealing with Zeke and Jerry Jones is
like making it worse and worse and worse
every time he talks and they're dealing
with DAC and they're dealing with Amari
Cooper and I thought the quote that was
the most interesting thing about Jerry
Jones that he said was someone asked you
know are you confident you can get team
friendly deals done with DAC Zeke and
Amar'e and he said look I'm not gonna
speculate but the way to get this deal
done is people have to have a little
more thought about team and that's
certainly in Jalen's mind so what Jerry
Jones is saying is Jalen is not taking
the highest-paid linebacker I think he
ended up being somewhere around like 8
or 9 he's taking a team friendly deal
and we're gonna pay him Jalen is our
friend and we'll pay him it's just it's
setting me up to really not have faith
that Zeke's can
come back right because if Jerry is
coming out there being like you need to
take a team friendly deal and Zeke's
like no it's really fun when a
multi-billionaire tells people that are
trying to get their multi-million dollar
contract that they need to like really
you know think about the team if we're
gonna win you need to take less
go [ __ ] yourself bro go [ __ ] yourself a
billionaire sure absolutely I don't know
why fans aren't like cagey about this
like like people cuz fans they want the
best team possible so sometimes they're
rooting for their favorite athletes to
take a slightly less money in order to
help the team and I get that like we're
all aware of salary deals but it just
feels very disingenuous for a person
who's worth 510 I don't know billion
dollars to say hey you should instead of
taking you know eighty million dollar
contract it would be really great if you
took a sixty million dollar contract
because you know hey be there for the
team it's like dude you're a billionaire
yes but I do think that I was right
originally when Jerry thought that him
defending Zeke was the reason he thought
he had leverage because when he was
asked about the joke where he said Zeke
ooh he said I've earned the right to
joke about Zeke and I was like you
believe that he owes you something
you absolutely do and you know what
there's probably a part of Zeke that
does owe Jerry Jones a little bit but
you have one chance to make your money I
just think that I have a feeling that
Zeke is gonna miss at least a game or
two and if Toni Pollard is as good as
they think he is and they're able to win
some games they will get the leverage
but if they're not if they lose to the
Giants in week one which would be
crushing to them and let's say the
running game starts out slow I don't
have confidence in Jerry like everyone
would go oh they got to pay Zeke now I
have a feeling that Jerry is gonna
double down this is my prediction that
if they lose earlier the running games
not great that Jerry Jones is gonna
double down on that sentiment and saying
that Zeke needs to be more of a team
player he needs to help us or this
season's gonna get away from us it's
like politicians they're just playing
like they they think that they can get
51% of Cowboys fans on their side if
they say X Y or Z I I think that if it
starts out slow and Jerry calls out Zeke
for being not a team player we might not
see Zeke Wow I just think it could make
it worse but he might still be on my
fantasy team at that point and then I a
real right to complain
the only thing I wanted to say before we
get to the whoa big offseasons is the
Baker Mayfield GQ comments about Daniel
Jones and it's interesting because this
is the third time in my recent
recollection where a prominent NFL
player is claiming to be taken out of
context
one was Odell Beckham where comments
about leaving the Giants came out in an
article about him getting ready to walk
the red carpet for what's the big Vanity
Fair party there was the Baker Mayfield
one and then the one that I'm less
inclined to believe is the Jalen Ramsey
one where he talked a lot of [ __ ]
and what's interesting is the quote the
quote was I cannot believe that Giants
took Daniel Jones
blows my mind some people overthink it
what makes a good quarterback that's
where they go wrong they forget you've
got to win then Dacre Mayfield came out
and said that he actually reached out to
jail Daniel Jones to clear the air
clarify the comments he was confused
about the GQ story because that wasn't
what the conversation was and then what
happened it split into two factions in
the media some people going hmm I wonder
what actually happened here and the
other one going the media is never wrong
why would they take this out of context
maybe you should stop [ __ ] talking to
people oh it's always the media's fault
and it turns into like this weird like
enemy of the state turning into like
backlash of media feeling sensitive
because of all the Donald Trump stuff
and like bleeding over into sports where
they're like it's not the media's fault
and I want to say that media if you also
want to say that you're human all the
time when people attack you also say
that you're human sometimes and you take
people out of [ __ ] context and I
don't know what happened I just know
this that if I'm an NFL athlete and I'm
about to do a day-long photoshoot with
GQ and I'm shooting the [ __ ] with a
reporter that time and I've been dealing
with NFL reporters that get me at max 15
minutes of the time and there's probably
a point the interview where I'm sitting
across from you and we're doing a formal
interview that probably the shoot in
this [ __ ] part probably hasn't been
outlined to me that all of that stuff is
also fair game yeah yeah I think it's
there needs to also be a human aspect of
these athletes where like
you're getting 12 hours of like like I
just don't expect GQ to get any more
interviews like this or it better be
like this is off the record I just think
that I worry that these guys are being
taken advantage of sometimes it's the
same reporter and all this [ __ ] ingmar
yeah I looked it up in my ideal world
you know when you read an article that's
like here's what happened in a certain
trial and by the way if you want to read
the entire trial here's a 400 page link
right I wish in sports that this could
happen that he's like here's what the
quote was and here's a gigantic
transcript of everything we talked about
that day that would be my ideal world
net like if you were some intrepid
reporter you could go in and find out
was it actually out of context or not
because I don't again I don't know what
happened but I do feel like quote I was
taken out of context end quote has
become like a crutch for some people
after they regret saying something
I think the phrase sucks taken out of
context it's because that's that's
that's just becoming a racist I think
that was way harsher than what I meant
because a lot of people the sentiment
might have been that Baker still felt
that taking Daniel just we can't say
which is probably the truth honestly we
were shooting the [ __ ] I didn't know he
was recording and I would never say
those sentiments publicly right but that
means he still believes those things
yeah which is fine taking out of context
is the same thing as my account has been
hacked has you know I mean like it's at
we don't believe you it makes us not
believe you but really in my mind it's
if I'm doing a cover story with GQ and
they tell me what it's gonna be about
and then you throw in two to three
paragraphs where I'm [ __ ] on another
guy and it's completely like apropos to
nothing and there was no reason for
being the story you're putting in there
to get clicks Pro you are and you're
taking a moment in a 12 hour session
where the athlete probably didn't know
he was on the record cuz in - can I tell
you something I know that's what
happened to Odell Beckham hmm I have
sources yeah that when he did his
interview that he was like talking about
fashion for three [ __ ] hours and he's
talking about what he's wearing and that
was the whole point of the piece and
then a kid like there was a random
conversation about the Giants and then
that's what they led with and that's
what they put in all their promo [ __ ]
yeah and he was not trying to do that
and so and they say those articles for
like two months and they release it like
when it's in the prime NFL like why
Baker Mayfield say this now he said it
three months ago when nobody was [ __ ]
talking about things about that
especially like that happens all the
time when someone films a commercial
right it's like a commercial with Peyton
Manning comes on right after Peyton
Manning throws an interception though
like well you should stop screwing
around recording commercials it's like
he did that eight months ago probably
yes he probably recorded that eight
months ago and now he's playing football
and you know what I mean like people
don't think about that timing stuff yeah
but people are like oh he got taken out
of context when he completely said those
things and it's like we have been going
through shooting this show booking
people's times and allocating time and
all that stuff and it's like if I was
talking to an NFL player that's going to
be on ditch the PlayBook this season and
we were having a conversation and the
cameras were rolling in the mic was
going on and an NFL player said honestly
I think Bill Belichick cheats all the
time I'm not [ __ ] airing it because I
know that that was a when you change the
tone of your voice or you're not
directly standing in front of camera
yeah I'm not [ __ ] airing that ask any
sound guy in the world what's the
craziest thing you've ever heard they're
like oh dude named you know celebrity
actor a yes I heard them say this that
and the other but we're not gonna do it
because they didn't know they were being
recorded at the time they just had a mic
on there and so I'm not trying to pick a
fight with every [ __ ] media member
that's traditional media outlets that's
typically a written reporter because god
forbid they ever get questioned my thing
is just like I'd be willing to bet a
large sum of money that he didn't
realize and if you're gonna come to me
and go well he should know he's talking
to a reporter come a [ __ ] down like
you're not you're not reporting on like
state secrets right now you're not
reporting on things that actually matter
no you [ __ ] use that kid and like if
your whole thing is then guess what like
I'm gonna tell you that everything is
off the record everything and then
afterwards we'll sit down we'll figure
out what we want to use you know I mean
like I'll make those decisions later yes
I just think it's a dangerous game am I
getting too emotional about this it's
fine I like it because you're you look
you like protecting the players that's
right I've been the reporter like I've
been on that side and I know what it
takes to like acquire time with these
guys and this might be a thing off to
the side but can
just say I want to live in a world where
it's okay for one quarterback to say
that a different quarterback wasn't a
great draft pick and that's an okay
reasonable opinion to have like you
might think he was a little too effusive
in the way he said it you might think
hey you know these players they
shouldn't be knocking each other they
should be building each other up it's
like they're rivals they should want to
beat each other I think that the brown
should want to beat Daniel Jones in the
Super Bowl like it's fine for these guys
to talk trash we shouldn't like have a
referendum on the state of sports
because Baker Mayfield thinks that
Daniel Jones was not a great pick before
he's thrown a single pass we should be
okay with that we should be encouraging
players to say you know kind of cool
takes about each other oh you know what
I love I just realized I love the fact
that it's a Midwest City that never gets
respect against New York New York City I
love that it's Dave Gettleman versus
John Dorsey
I love that it's Odell feeling
disrespected
I love that it's Baker may feel going oh
that's your new king [ __ ] your new like
there is something about that and I wish
they could play this year I can already
tell you the NFL's probably circle in
that to make that a Monday night Sunday
Night Football game next year
Cleveland will be in town week two to
play the New York Jets and the left
coast show will be tailgating doing a
live show that's how I'm gonna wrap that
up yeah I'm not saying that anyone there
was right I just okay I'm done
Nick it is time for us to take a stroll
down to
[Applause]
[Music]
big offseason way to be on it Nick by
the way that last big offseason that is
Nick's voice a picture grande all right
first one comes from a joint practice
between the Eagles and the Ravens Jimmy
Kemp ski Philly reporter he said Lamar
Jackson just juked the blank out of lj4
it's so badly that fort went to the
ground drew an O from both sides
or you think was an I don't know what
it's it's a bunch of O's with an H at
the end is that an O I think it's an O
Oh
I think the ain't changes it from an O
to an O got it from both side lines I
honestly thought for a second fort might
have torn an ACL LOL first of all don't
hello al someone's torn ACL that's why I
think Jimmy is very funny though Jimmy
is this guy that if you follow up also
do like stick figure art time what I
love is now I needed this it's the
second offseason in a row where Lamar
Jackson is drawn whose Oro's yeah last
year they were like oh and then he
busted someone up but I'm very confident
Lamar Jackson you know who else drew OHS
every single player at every pickup game
ever for doing like one cool crossover
and hitting a J like that's why it's a
great next one is I think a good
commentary on just preseason football in
June sheriff's from Dave Lombardi Kyle
Shanahan on first team offense if you
get concern to over 10 plays
that's pretty irresponsible so pretty
much what Kyle Shannon is doing right
there is being like you're not realizing
that you're whoa big offseason I think
well I had people coming up to me in
Vegas going you worried about Jimmy
Garoppolo like I'm seeing reputable NFL
media people being like he threw five
interceptions of practice yeah
whoa big offseason like who the [ __ ]
cares this isn't real like everybody was
going after the first game Kyler Murray
and this offense could be electric after
the second game sucks what the [ __ ] is
wrong with kind of American I had then
Kliff Kingsbury came out and said we ran
the same play like we're not running
like we're not doing anything and then
when Kyler Murray came up to Antonio
Brown was like you know you guys were
blitzing me the whole game I like that's
what you're
face but calimary is kind of right where
he's like sure you can blitz me all you
want but like why are you doing this in
the preseason like everyone goes you
can't learn anything from the preseason
because everyone plays vanilla and then
when one team plays chocolate when one
team brings a full-out blitz were like
what's wrong with this team and it's
like they're playing vanilla it's just
Kyle Shanahan's right calm the [ __ ] down
open golf's Eric car right before that
game we were going back to Hard Knocks
now but Derrick horribly he's like all
right guys let's go out there let's win
one two three win right I really wish
that in an alternate universe he was
like all right guys let's go out there
let's run through our progressions let's
get a lot of guys involved let's make
sure the third and fourth stringers
getting their play healthy and let's
make sure that you know the final score
doesn't matter because this is just
preseason all right one two three and
then they all repeat everything that he
does that's their cheer gonna keep it
light and we're gonna keep on our
progression yeah so I think um it's Kyle
Shanahan Sean McVeigh I love Sean
McVeigh it's just completely just flip
the script on the the preseason he's
like I'm just not gonna play any of my
guys and yet and yet all I ever hear
when I say that I'm betting on
pre-season people say what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you and then when I say the
preseason doesn't matter in terms of
performance they got it all no preseason
matters in terms of this preseason
matters in terms of usage preseason
matters in terms of formational usage
the only thing I'm looking at for
preseason genuinely is rookies and how
they look that's our first time we get a
glimpse of them because they're busting
their asses out there and then when Ben
Roethlisberger is out there for 14 plays
James Connors out there for 14 plays and
Vance McDonald is out there for 14 plays
I'm looking at usage because in years
past it might be James Conner 8 and then
Jalen Samuels 4 and then I'm going oh
might be a rotation James Conner is the
guy yeah you know so that's the [ __ ]
that matters okay when they go 11
formation there's three wide receivers
out there who's in the slot because
that's the [ __ ] that they're actually
trying out I'm looking to see where
people are and the frequency of which
they're playing the results of the plays
do not matter to me now there are
certain people where I go Tina Johnson
looks a little slow I'll factor that
away but like successive play calls go
[ __ ] yourself
but it's I'm really cursing a lot all
right last Mobe golf season I kind of
put in there for you because it's kind
of ridiculous and I'm gonna use this
betting wise in two ways
so gloat in the glory of this whoa big
officer yeah I'm just gonna read this
and just let it like drip down my mouth
like a beautiful steak this is the most
at from Tucker Boynton in the last six
regular and postseason the Patriots are
41 and three that's a 932 winning
percentage at Gillette after week for
the last time Brady and Belichick lost
at home regular season game after week
four by more than a possession was week
9 2005 versus I assume Peyton Manning's
Colts unless that was like a random
Curtis Painter week 14 years ago yeah is
the last time that the Patriots lost at
Gillette after week four so there's a
few ways I'm gonna use this the Patriots
I would say for the last decade have
been very hit or miss in the first five
to six weeks of the season we remember
every article that's come out saying
this is against tier two and three the
most famous one being the three
interception game against Kansas City
when the reporters were asking are you
gonna go to Jimmy Garoppolo and that was
we're on to Cincinnati right Lana since
no that was 41 to 14 that game is the
most famous example of this last year
they lost I think they almost lost to
the Texans they lost that they lost a
game at the Titans and all that stuff in
betting the Patriots this year I'm going
to bet against them early mm-hmm and I'm
gonna bet with them late okay now the
problem with betting with the Patriots
after week four is that the line suck
yeah they're favored by 13 but in weeks
four five six and seven the lines have
not reached that point yet so early on
I'm gonna fade the Patriots you're kind
of thinking like a boxer right we're
like Floyd Mayweather doesn't have to
win the first round he's feeling you out
and that's what they think of as the
month of September salutely I'm just
feeling out my opponents feeling a part
of me that thinks that Bill Belichick
runs very generic offense and defense
the first because especially defense his
defense the first few weeks every year
were like what is real like they let up
like 34 points to the Panthers two years
ago like 37 points to the Texans and we
go what the [ __ ] and
and like from that this is two seasons
ago that Thursday night game against
Tampa Bay on they were the number one
scoring defense in the NFL there's part
of me that thinks that Belichick says I
think that we could be generic enough to
go two and three three into the first
few weeks and nobody any [ __ ]
background information and then we can
stickers we'll have all the background
information on everybody else and will
steamroll and by the time you've figured
out in weeks eleven and twelve I've
adjusted again and you can't even use
you can't even use that background
information to make it happen yeah and I
I don't know there's something to that
and so right now I'm just letting you
guys from a betting perspective I'm
gonna fade the Patriots early how the
Patriots week seek through six through
twelve and everyone's questioning them
and maybe I get it and then stay away
when they're favored but I think this is
smart this I look it sounds good
the Patriots are the only thing that you
can say something consistent about year
after year they're the only team we can
be like this is what they do in
September this is what they do in
December it is what they do in the
playoffs is the only team where that's
actually remotely accurate over any sort
of sustained length of time that feels
really smart also how did you feel when
you found out that Josh Gordon got
reinstated I was delighted I mean Josh
Gordon is amazing I feel like I said
this to Manziel I hope he gets I hope
yes the personal help that he needs but
I really feel like this
people were saying Josh Gordon in New
England this is his last chance if it
doesn't work out there it won't work
anywhere and what's funny is a lot of
people think about the downside of that
they go oh it could all be over but what
they're not realizing is the phrase if
it doesn't work there won't work
anywhere means this is the best
situation for him mm-hmm
and that's what I think it is I think
he's got ton if Tom Brady puts his arm
around you and says we can make history
maybe you can fight those demons if Bill
Belichick who every player I've ever
held had come on this show goes he's the
guy he can speak to you like a man and
there's no [ __ ] there's no ulterior
motive I'm hoping it turns around at the
same point [ __ ] you guys like I mean
other teams are just jealous because we
picked up Josh Gordon and like that's
the ultimate sign
that you guys have two decades of
infrastructure of consistency of a
machine where there's no reinventing the
wheel there's no trying new stuff it's
this is our system and this is what we
do and it's beautiful it's beautiful no
nobody gets upset about you know the
great businesses and all that stuff but
they look at Bezos and they get jealous
yeah and and you guys are [ __ ]
incredible we have Josh Gordon and Jared
Stidham on the same roster can you
believe it you're a loving Jared's love
Jared Stidham that was fun
so I'm hoping to be able to officially
announce to you guys next week
the some co-hosts I swear to god they're
happening and then next week I want to
do my big season prediction stuff where
I'm going to pick the division champions
the Super Bowl winner all that stuff and
then the week after that we're ramping
up to the first week of the year
Thursday night September 5th
bears-packers hundred-year-old rivalry
and the day before that Wednesday night
first episode of ditch the playbook oh
how I'll indeed for ingmar for Nick in
the back love you guys holla holla holla
kick some ass in the let's [ __ ] go
league and then also I should always do
this before your setup I want to see
your setup for the draft I want to see
what you guys are doing [ __ ] love
y'all enjoy yourselves holla holla holla
talk to you later
[Music]